and it's to Brazil now we're outgoing
president Jaya bolsonaro has broken his
silence over his election defeat in his
first public address in Sunday's vote
bolsonarus signaled he will authorize
the transition of power to his livering
rival Lou Leta Silva however he stopped
short of conceding he also thanked his
supporters who've been protesting and
blocking roads since election night
tear gas and rubber bullets fired at
bolsonaro's supporters
since election results were released
protesters have been blocking dozens of
Highways and public roads across the
country refusing to recognize
bolsonaro's defeat to rival Lula de
Silva
we won't accept losing what we have
conquered so far we want order and
progress to Prevail
a man who's been in jail cannot govern
our country I can't agree with that
unlike his supporters it took bolsonaro
almost two days to break his silence on
the election outcome when he finally
appeared in public he did not concede
the feat instead he said he would comply
with the Constitution and that protests
would be welcome if peaceful
all of these demonstrations are
happening because people feel angry they
are a reflection of the Injustice in our
election
peaceful demonstrations will always be
welcome but our way to do things cannot
be that of the left
following bolsonaro's comments his chief
of staff announced that the outgoing
president had authorized the transition
process to begin Lula da Silva is
expected to be sworn in in January
out in the streets the demonstrations
caused flight cancellations and
transport disruptions in several cities
and some fear they could go on for
months
and let's get more on the transfer of
power in Brazil with Mac Margolis
Margolis he's a columnist for the
Washington Post covering Brazil and
Latin America it's good to have you on
the program Mac what do you think are
you surprised that bolsonaro is seeding
power without much of a fight
uh good morning I am good afternoon for
you I I am a little surprised but when
you look at the his track record over
the last four years uh it's it's totally
within keeping of of his profile he's
Bolson honor has always been more of a
word Warrior than an action hero uh and
sometimes he almost tries to be
presidential but um basically he is a
master at whipping up the crowd but he
doesn't have much
um institutional support so I I think as
his allies I've told him whispered in
his ear that the game was over he he
stepped back
um I I would say one thing that the
campaign for all the worry we heard over
the last months about the campaign being
nasty and possibly bloody it went much
smoother than anticipated
um and and that's a that's a very good
sign for Brazil which is an incredibly
polarized
and do you reckon the there's anything
to be made of the fact that he's not
explicitly conceited he's not even
acknowledged lose win
yeah that does matter in in so far is
that's what you do in a democracy when
when you lose you concede you do so
publicly and and it's it's a courtesy to
your supporters this silence uh this
48-hour silence that bolsonaro kept was
a disrespect to his own supporters
um but the the fact is that
um
this is again in keeping with with
bolsonaro's
style
um he um has often had shown the
appetite for a coup right but not the
stomach
um and the uh people all around him his
key alleys in Congress in the Ministries
and in the armed forces especially
um basically told him
in no uncertain terms that the game was
over
many analysts say that bolsonaro's term
in office was it was a trying period uh
for Brazil's democracy
um what policies are likely to change
now that Lula will take over
well that's that's a huge question now
and um I don't think that you'll even
get a straight answer from Lula I mean
it's it's significant that to win Lula
who's known as a an iconic
leader on the left in Brazil
um head of the workers party for years
and the the leading left figure in
Brazil had to move very uh very uh
forcefully to the middle uh the
political middle to run his a successful
Campaign which is what he did 20 years
ago when he first won the presidency he
had to drop the very leftist and
confrontational posture to embrace
the wide spectrum of views that exist in
Brazil that he made that clear in his
victory speech that Brazil is not
divided into many uh different
ideological it is divided into many
ideological groups but they're all part
of Brazil there's only one Brazil not
many Brazil's the the question will be
how to keep uh control of those uh those
many forces which will pull him in many
different directions
Ram
mag Margolis there columnist for the
Washington Post thank you Mac we
appreciate your insights
thank you